Now let's look at how a developer may use this primitus in building a sub
system. The first part of the code is going to be the initialization portion
where the developer is mapping the address
space of his process to external segments.
Chosen regions of the address base to
external data segments. And also specifying what
the log segment is going to be for this
particular code base that he or she is writing.
And in the body of the code, there are
going to be regions where they want to manipulate persistent data
structures. And for that portion of the code they're
going to say begin transaction, end transaction and within there
the first thing that we'll do is set the
range to indicate what is the block of contiguous
adversities that they plan to modify in this critical
section. And of course this block of adversaries should
be contained in the range that has been mapped
to an external data segment. And once they have
done that, then the rest of the code is
normal code that they write in terms of manipulating
data structures. So they may be writing to a
data structure m1, which is really a metadata that
needs to persisted. And, if that is the case it is important that the
user ensure that this data structure m1 is contained
in the range that they specified at the beginning. And similarly m2 if it is
a another persistent data structure that they're modifiying, it
better be contained in the range again that they set
out in the beginning. And similarly, when they are done
with all of the changes and they want to commit,
they can call end transaction and at that
point all the changes that they made to
these data structures are going to be written
as a redo log into the log segment.
So the first thing that LRVM would do
inside this transaction code, is when you execute
the set range call, it says, aha, this
is the portion of the address range that the
developer is going to modify within this critical section. And
it's possible that this transaction, which is beginning now,
may commit or abort. If in fact it aborts,
then I have to make sure that all the changes
that are made to persist in data structures are
thrown away at the point of abort. And therefore the
first thing that LRVM does is create what is
called an undo record, which is really a copy of
the virtual address base starting at this base
address for this number of bytes. That's the portion
of the address base that the developer intends
to modify within this critical section. So LRVM makes
an undo record which is the original version
of that portion of the address base. So this
under record is an in memory copy of the
virtual address base starting here, for some number of
bites specified by this number of bytes. And this is a temporary record, and in
fact LRVM will create this under record only if it is needed by
this transaction semantic. In the bigger transaction,
there is a mode specifier, that the
user can specify to the RVM whether
this particular transaction is going ever abort.
So in other words, if the developer is
absolutely certain. That his transaction is never going
to abort, then he can specifiy and know
restore mode for this transaction, which tells RVM,
that, look this transaction is never going to
abort, therefore no need for you to create
an undo record. That's the intent of that.
So, again, we want to make sure that these
primitives are performant. This is one of the
ways by which the application developer can make
sure that LRVM does not do unnecessary work.
And in this case, if this transaction is never
going to abort, then there is no reason
to create an undo record. So that's the idea
behind the no restore mode in the begin
transaction. In any event, if the transaction eventually commits,
at that point LRVM with throw away
this undo record. This undo record is meaningful
only if the transaction aborts because in
that case. What LRVM would do is restore
the original version of this portion of
the virtual address space by copying the undo
record back into that space. So during the
body of this critical section, when the application
is modifying These in-memory version of persistent data structure,
no action by LRVM. All these changes are happening directly
to the virtual address space of that particular process exactly
where these in-memory copy of persistent data structures are living.